hello and welcome back to part two of
this special reality check series all
about survival and thriving in a
real-life fallout 76 world what is the
apocalypse I can make up words who's
gonna stop me last week professor Lewis
Darnell author of the knowledge how to
rebuild our world from scratch revealed
some crucial hints and tips on how to
survive those early days after emerging
from a real-life vault 76 if you haven't
seen it yet or simply want to rewatch my
incredible acting make sure you go and
do that now this week much as in fallout
76 now that we've mastered survival it's
time to move on to rebuilding and
reclaiming the landscape so the most
useful tool that you're gonna use in
flux every six is this camp system which
basically allows you to build anything
but in real life what is the the kind of
one tool I need one of the most useful
machine tools throughout history and
something you're going to need to use to
reboot your civilization again is the
lave if you don't know what a lathe is
you can actually see one a small version
on the right-hand side of camps and it's
essentially just a machine with two
spindles that allows you to turn
something in between and then move a
tool bit back and forth across it's how
you make something like the barrel of a
rifle or the cylinder of a steam engine
it's incredibly useful machine tool and
actually what's really cover really
cunning about a lathe is a lathe as a
machine that can create all of the parts
you need to make another leaf it's a
machine that can reproduce itself just
like an organism can is it's an
incredible concept and there's this
really interesting example of a machine
is called Dave Gendry who made a lathe
absolutely from scratch yeah nothing but
clay sand some charcoal as fuel and just
some old scrap drinks cans and he used
the forge to melt the aluminium pour
that multi-element even to a cast made
of sand
to make the different parts of a lathe
from scratch he built this workshop
nothing I think it's an incredible
real-life example and exactly what
you're doing for yourself in the fallout
76 game so there are loads of different
workbenches in the game that you can
make using camps maybe some are for
changing your armor or like tinkering
with your guns but like what's the one
that you would want if I could pick on a
single workbench it would definitely be
the chemists bench are you getting
fallout of 76 it's often overlooked -
just how useful basic chemistry is for
supporting at everyday lives and kind of
running the civilization behind the
scenes and what you can see in the
chemistry workbench in the game is still
something used for distilling perhaps
concentrated alcohol which we saw in the
first episode is really useful as a
solvent or as a disinfectant for wounds
you could use post-apocalyptic chemistry
for making gunpowder from scratch
yourself but there's even just really
simple chemistry behind making something
like soap to stop infection spreading
and again you dying of something that's
really easy to prevent and all you need
to do to make soap from scratch yourself
is trickle some water through the ashes
of a wood fire and you extract something
called potash or potassium carbonate
which is very alkaline and you then mix
that's potash and you've just made with
some boiling fat and that turns it into
soup
what about electricity and power because
full at 76 that's like the first thing
the game tells you to make sure you do
even if it's just a build a big sign
that says go away leave me alone is
electricity zap there zap priority in
the aftermath of a real-life apocalypse
you're going to want to keep your
lifestyle electrified you're gonna want
to be able to the benefits of electric
light and not go to bed every time
there's a sunset you're gonna want to be
able to use the technology and
appliances lying around that run
electricity the question is how do you
make electricity of yourself once the
grid goes down so is that a case of just
like scavenging bits and bobs you find
lying around or like a solar panel here
or yeah so getting the immediate
aftermath you could scavenge things like
solar panels or actually probably more
usefully kind of mobile diesel
generators those sort of things you see
by the roadworks or internal
construction sites scavenge a couple of
those connect them together and
Electrify your community right so I
guess that that requires you finding you
know fuel for these things so but what
if what if there's no fuel Lois like
what then we could use your chemistry
workshop to create biodiesel or bio
ethanol again you can use alcohol as a
fuel but let's assume that that's all
starting to run out or you want to use
your fuel for other purposes you can
actually run machinery and and car
engines using nothing more than wood as
a fuel and this is a process known as
gasification you heat wood and in a
container without letting too much
Auction get in and it breaks down and
gives off gases producer gases which you
can then point and burn it and this was
really important during the Second World
War with all the fuel shortages back
then there are over a million gasifier
powered cars wood powered cars driving
along the streets of Europe powered by
wood but what if we gonna learn from our
mistakes to lose I mean we might want to
use that fuel for it for other things
but also we might want to go green in
the post apocalypse and so what kind of
renewables can we take advantage of
given the kind of limited resources
we'll have so you might go to one of
your work benches like you find in the
game and use the hammer anvil or the
forge
you repurpose scrap metal you find lying
around you can create the blades of a
wind turbine or a binding for yourself
you could start scavenging the gearing
systems from something like a bike to
turn that rotation from your wind
turbine to make it faster but the one
component you will need that converts
spinning into electricity is a generator
or a dynamo and the best place to find
one of those when you're scavenging is
the alternator in in any abandoned car
and you can use that alternator to
provide electricity for your off-grid
network and specifically to recharge
batteries so that could reach are just a
normal car battery which is what it does
in a car but actually even better than
that is what's known is a deep-cycle
lead-acid battery and this is a kind of
battery that you can charge up and then
completely empty and lots of times
without it degrading to you badly and
the best place to find that kind of
battery is from a golf buggy so maybe
one of the best places to go to for
scavenging after an apocalypse would be
the golf course I hope you've enjoyed
this two-part reality check special all
about survival and rebuilding in a
fallout 76 world also a huge thanks must
go to our experts professor Luis Darnell
for being - such a lovely and mild
mannered guest burn your enemies burn
them afire kill them afire
are you excited to put this new
knowledge to the test when you jump into
full at 76 in just a week's time let me
know in the comments down below or by
tweeting to me directly at cam Fraser
Rob thanks for watching
[Music]
played on the world's most powerful
console